c'est le mot de marine le pen banco ce
plus de 16 millions 10,7 millions de
manifestement c'est la france
soleil le soleil ne se couche jamais sur
oui
parler d'immigration ou de sécurité pour
il peut être difficile de regarder les
tandis que montaient sans cesse à cordys
chiffres c'est assez clair dans
de l'autre côté il y à d'autres projets
le mondialisme et la brutalité qui lui
république il avance 46 minutes de
vraiment étonné son attitude hier soir
regardons l'histoire des élections
qui programment une déréglementation
ils sont quand même payer cher pour un
prospérer ne crime crapuleux et les
il a eu sa chance
rassemblement national et le front
à eric zemmour et puis moins à l'aise
les ami es monté sans cesse le coût de
notre drapeau est l'étendard de la
discours de marine le pen avec cette
là et 2 à ah ah
boutiquière entrave les décisions
tradition comme ça et évidemment elle en
donc elle va sans doute accès une grande
cette campagne je n'ai pas entendu un
métropole et d'outre-mer et du monde
confirmation
une affaire qui a un peu
moment où tu pourras te rendre justice
vous sur l'attitude affichée par le
ses principaux rivaux et mais c'est
publics au milieu du village la gare au
parce que le choix de pouvoir profiter
n'est pas de persécuter ou de ruiner les
oui je pense à eux oui nos compatriotes
sincérité
communication cette faute de
l'heure est venue pour toi de mettre un
appelons les français à faire barrage à
droit à aucun français au contraire je
violence
proposer un bilan un programme sur les
et nous remettrons particulièrement à
concept qui a une cinquantaine d'années
depuis sa un président qui hausse les
de france qui fera entrer notre pays
second mandat qui irait donc plus loin
nonchalant
candidature d'eric zemmour donc le fn
présidentielles sous la vème république
peut-être tenté une annonce choc quelque
on évoque cette insécurité sept ans
barrage on ne s'abstient pas on va pas
téléspectateurs en 2017 c'était
son dédain c'est celui avec laquelle
but que nous menons campagne depuis des
avril 2002 tout le monde s'en souvient
statut des enseignants est lui déjà
c'est toujours le cas en sortant c'est
mais où sont ils allés chercher ça
national
lesquelles je crois chaque français ne
sommes la seule alternative face au
n'est pas exagéré de soutenir que le
général un effacement de l'état et une
mais
importante dans ce discours il ya un
avec laquelle mon adversaire
peuple a congédié
sera macron où la france elle joue sur
fin de meeting elle vise à construire
ne pourrait pas arriver en france est ce
quand on prend toutes les toutes les
chers compatriotes chers compatriotes de
résultat assez minable on a vu défiler
direct j moins 3 avant le second tour de
et puis regardez les chiffres en face à
il a eu sa chance lui sourit il a
source d'inquiétude
contre ceux qui ont si peu de
belle jeunesse de france cette jeunesse
pas du tout attaqué marine le pen elle
toi et entend cet appel
communication et maintenant que cette
longue anaphore peuple de france lève
mafias qui alimente depuis vingt ans les
peuple de france va demander des comptes
si la majorité silencieuse décide de
l'heure on attend un discours pas
emmanuel macron 1 parce que pour faire
de sa retraite en bonne santé est un
dans les urnes approche
qu'il ya des différences vous me dites
épaules quand on lui parle de
seul argument valable contre menton
le pen 31% donc un peu en dessous mais
partie de son discours sur ce point même
nécessaires au bien commun comme on l'a
dans l'économie de la connaissance
terme à la glissade à la course vers le
l'entre-deux-tours emmanuel macron a
français qui ont besoin de leur voiture
est l'ol en profite la limite c'est que
il nous semble qu'on ne peut pas être
ont associé qui lui sont qui lui est
la vie et que disparaissait par millions
milieu du village
annoncé
difficile pour eux de paraître proche
élections mais il ya évidemment un
président candidat tout au long de ce
que le saccage en cours
choix de dimanche prochain sera un choix
d'abord exposé son programme avant de
s'agissant de la proposition de mon
d'ailleurs un petit peu moins hier soir
sauvagement qui blesse dans leur chair
sûr nous ferons de la protection de
liberté
peut que constater quotidiennement
système une alternative populaire et
est en position de force 2 et rennes est
peuples qui cesse d'espérer cesse
l'honneur l'article 1 de notre
concept de majorité silencieuse qui ne
et on va pour le seul front qu'ils
inm ou somme il ne vous a sans doute pas
qualifié de condescendants d'arrogant
et vous le savez personne ne peut croire
et plus particulièrement l'évolution des
forcément très long 45 minutes une heure
mois que nous parcourons les villes et
que ça pourrait arriver mais pourquoi
privatisation de la décision publique
le peuple de france
ce clivage c'est important pour elle
chose en tout cas qui puisse réveiller
emmanuel macron est tellement
il faut ignorer la france ait ignoré le
attachement à ces territoires mais mais
je vous le dis solennellement
notre projet est l'exact contraire de
sera aussi le retour d'une justice
est-ce que ça aussi c'est une formule
avec lequel il traite les français
est restée plus sur son programme elle a
chiffre qui fait bondir cette moyenne
considération pour la défense de notre
sotak au référendum
l'élection présidentielle dernière ligne
donc très visible très lisible tout le
tôt on va analyser tout ce qui s'est dit
personnalité des manuels macron
pour aller travailler
celle de la révolution numérique de la
l'immigration massive et anarchique qui
barrage il faut voter emi pour faire
en position de force ensuite reconquête
cette mobilisation électorale peuple de
vraiment séduit une bonne partie des
désavantages à ddd éléments avec le des
élément de difficultés c'est qu'elle n'a
des gens c'est en tout cas ça a été
si hier soir à l'assemblée un peu en
une dizaine de combats mais à la salle
échéance très importante est passé eh
les ministres hagard et la litanie des
vu pour la santé l'hôpital les personnes
l'échec de la politique macro nist son
regarder les sondages et je dirais que
rangs des terroristes auxquels la france
président si on ne peut pas ou qu'on ne
à ces liquidateurs pour défendre ton
le rends reconnaîtrait de nouveau
sortir de son silence en votant être
cartes et sur les banlieues quartier
n'emboîte pas le pas aux instigateurs
sa campagne d'entre deux tours avec une
le moment où tu pourras relégué au rang
choix de société
projet pas un sel et pour cause ce
déclin dans les quais dans laquelle tu
il est encore temps je dirais même il
soient républicains le front anti macro
aussi elle s'en sert oui complètement
les deux derniers jours oui c'est de
révélatrice d'un quinquennat de
temps de nos compatriotes peu dans
marchons ensemble sur ce chemin de
d'exister mais quand je vous vois si
sur tout le territoire nous favoriserons
alors
commencé presque 25 minutes en parlant
adversaire
les emplois dont nous avons tant besoin
les le sondage français est plus fiable
tout au plus figaro live on se retrouve
territoriale
associé pardon je reprends ses termes et
d'outre-mer ne quitte jamais mon coeur
pour parler de son projet pour la pour
depuis bientôt cinq ans tout cela ne me
constitution que je vous lis la france
avec frédéric michaud qui est toujours
l'environnement le fil rouge de notre
limite un président ne devrait pas se
une vision qui réduit les relations
s'exprimeraient que dans les urnes et
difficulté face au chef de l'état qui a
sociale face à ce pouvoir oligarchique
surtout montré qu'il était
droite dernier moment pour essayer de
c'est l'ensemble des fondations de notre
l'a fait entrer dans notre pays un
a payé le prix du sang
mesurée cette fois ci pour pour emmanuel
les villages de notre beau pays nous
l'écologie c'est une révolution consenti
conseillé par mckinsey si c'est le cas
monde pour ne pas savoir que sur tous
c'est aussi pour montrer cette volonté
etc ensuite il ya eu un long
france lève toi voilà le message de
intentions de vote dans l'entre-deux
aura du mal à s'implanter alors que le
il faut savoir dépasser ce que renvoie
échappé
bien oui elle peut vraiment se focaliser
pas eu un positionnement clair avec des
je le dit hier soir la république vivra
civilisation
2030 voilà comment il a intitulé son son
une république indivisible
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
ont entraîné les dirigeants quittent ont
il ya un écart énorme et et il n'y a pas
c'est dans la nature même des hommes
j'assume une réforme des retraites à 60
est un jeune parti et donc il n'a pas de
que le sondage américain alors d'abord
arguments habituels de ceux d'ailleurs
c'est 2002 danseurs fameux 82% de
tout à l'heure et on écoute marine le
qui est cette nuit un des rendez vous
déstabiliser l'adversaire je voudrais
transition écologique cette jeunesse qui
elle retourne l'argument du front
mais cette hostilité n'est pas à l'égard
en ces heures de choix essentiel pour le
délitement démocratique
avec moi avant ça on reste un peu arras
que l'empilement des incompétences
convaincre pour essayer de renverser la
d' emmanuel macron c'est pas le même
permettez moi de revenir un peu avec
d'inutiles even tensions depuis cinq ans
l'ordre du possible on voit maintenant
en situation de handicap ou en état de
triomphera elle cessera enfin de se
monde a compris qu'il y avait une
fierté et de prospérité
chacun doit pouvoir profiter à ce
honneur
position qui était doublement
qui ont dénigré ton histoire ta culture
peuple de france lève toi je suis prête
celui d' emmanuel macron il a qu'une
bilan économique est aussi
politique car elle est une des facettes
son quinquennat fut une séquence confuse
convié cinq ans de plus un président qui
politiques de pas prendre les choses
développement tels coeur de son de son
nombreux si enthousiaste je sens chez
elles sont très très peu d'autonomie
parce qu'ils sont loin géographiquement
entre les personnes en rapport
de mauvais souvenir le règne de ces
formats médiatique avec lequel il est
ce pouvoir de quelques-uns au bénéfice
les continents il représente le symbole
tours on observe un fait n'y a jamais eu
marine le pen une dernière question
rassemblement national même s'il n'a pas
peuple de france lève toi
l'installation de pôles d'excellence
la banlieue quartier 2030 voilà le
de
grande pauvreté le sentiment d'abandon
est plus que temps de mettre fin à cette
macron et donc elle joue effectivement
dimanche ils devront enfin versé leur
avons fait cette campagne avec joie et
sur sur le fond de sa campagne et sur
campagnes nos villes moyennes
projet est parfaitement réalisable
invite à la liberté celle des personnes
état nation qui sont en danger
en fasses ta vision nationale
aujourd'hui 46 % seraient prêts à voter
est une république indivisible laïque
variations succès nature lorsqu'elle a
dimanche l'alternative est simple soit
campagne qui a commencé il ya plus d'un
trahi creil sans vergogne et sans trêve
pas la langue préférée nation et d'un
exercice
qu'on finisse frédéric avec avec cette
qui n'ont pas d'arguments l'anathème
également une renaissance démocratique
de sa volonté de représenter tous les
d'ailleurs depuis depuis une vingtaine
cela signifie aussi que nous pouvons
situation c'est ce que va essayer de
paraît pas très digne de notre
mené à un rythme soutenable
chacun hier soir a compris qu emmanuel
différence de niveau à l'époque et de
une marque et pour déplacer une marque
acquis qui bénéficie évidemment de sa
telles qu'elles sont mais au contraire
catastrophique oui celui qu'on nous
en majorité un vainqueur qui sort très
économique c'est-à-dire en rapport de
pays
le système électoral américain est très
puisse donner de la compétence et niveau
républicain et veut construire un front
les la campagne touche à sa fin les
le dans le débat hier soir son objectif
plus il est plus à l'aise peut-être que
innovants et d'industries de
nous donnera son énergie sa créativité
un chemin qui portent trois couleurs
inconfortable pour elle d'abord toute sa
programme pour les banlieues ce matin à
détresse sociale
est en écoute la marseillaise là oh
projet pour pour emmanuel macron qui a
arrogants cet immense
la dépression civique le décrochage du
cet effet de contraste à plein c'est
ans et 40 annuités pour les kaya précoce
majeurs de cette campagne présidentielle
faire imposer une politique qui la ruine
juridiquement applicable financièrement
de l'émancipation et du courage le monde
quand même on sait que la campagne se
hausse les épaules et ne se remet jamais
de l'amour que nous portons à notre pays
humilité avec sérieux et conviction et
du référendum mes chers amis cette
aujourd'hui elles sont vampirisé par les
faire ce soir marine le pen la candidate
anaphore peuple de france lève toi c'est
an c'est la dernière ligne droite et on
lève toi contre l'arrogance et le mépris
nous en faisons le signe de ralliement
fraternelle avec un état bienveillant
d'extrême droite répété à tort et à
d'années depuis l'inversion du
travailler jusqu'à l'épuisement pour une
juste et claire application d'une vision
démocratique
démocratie de la fonction présidentielle
de vouloir les transformer de vouloir
de quelques-uns nous ne voulons pas
discours sur le projet pour bien
des traditions
rencontré sa dame sur un marché à
solde de tout compte et quitter ce
marche effrénée qui nous mène nulle part
de croisement de courbes jamais eu de
depuis si longtemps
plus admettre que les territoires de
il gouverne ainsi
moment-là de la vie des petits matins ou
particulier c'est pas un système comme
compétences et de maîtrise des des
son bilan est accablant et dit ce qu'il
c'est le cas pour marine le pen en ce
vous cette volonté farouche de rester
le contenu d'image
son projet regardez ce que titrait ce
face à cette oligarchie froide qui
pour lui dimanche c'est seulement 29%
force souvent empreinte de mépris social
macron n'aimait pas les français et tout
et celle des peuples
point de vue d'un point de vue
accompagnés par des progrès techniques
à me redonner sa dignité tu as confiance
compétence d'anciens ministres de
français et quel qu'il soit dans dans
chaotique dont il ne reste qu'une
programmes ont été bien exposé bien
calendrier électoral qui avait été
transformation dans le cadre d'une
nous engagerons sans attendre le
c'est quand même un parti qui existe
qui s'achève je parle évidemment du
avait présenté comme un surdoué de la
commencé avant 20 ans mais jamais plus
va analyser tout ça avec frédéric
métropoles laissé à l'abandon à la
une le pen était donc on l'a suivi
c'était de corriger l'erreur de 2010 est
et sociale
qui ont fait de la submersion migratoire
qu'il abaisse qu'il a des classes
été tancé vous venez nous voir au
notre pays suivent des destinées
anti macron 6 le mot barrages elle
hostilité elle est l égard de vous
de tous les français
stratégie visait a axé sa campagne sur
profondément humaine il est aussi un
la vision mondialiste d' emmanuel macron
fièrement rien d'autre qu'un le bleu le
pays
peuple de france leur est venue du grand
notre projet est l'expression de la
d'une élite qui n'a eu de cesse de
oui
médiatique j'ai le commentaire d'agnès
d'une marque là ça prend plusieurs
donc d'un côté la politique d' emmanuel
travers comme si vous qui êtes ici comme
résultats emmanuel macron ne déroge pas
sa fougue et sa soif de conquérir le
renversement de tendance ne veut pas
nous regarde et attend que nous
termine demain soir à minuit qu'est ce
matin le figaro macron domine le pen
soutenable il est si près sérieux il a
clairement des perceptions des français
pension de misère jusqu'à la fin de ses
vivant cette envie de france malgré le
infléchir ces chiffres ça c'est le sens
laisser les logiques de l'argent celle
intéressant ça plusieurs significations
pouvoir qu'ils ont accaparé avec tant de
et du respect que l'on doit au peuple
surtout surtout avec cette conviction
ensemble à arras ce soir voilà ce qu'on
pour appliquer son seul programme c'est
aussi une élue locale qui d'ailleurs
particulièrement ceux qui ne sont pas
la bim qui se rapproche les milliers
encore et ils souffrent eux aussi et
dossiers et donc quelque chose de très
depuis depuis plusieurs années avec des
d' absence d'empathie et de brutalité
insister sur le côté réaliste réalisable
finance est en réalité un cancre
l'économie et donc qui est crédible
détaillé les mesures phares les mesures
pour marine le pen vous voyez il ya
qui nous dit sûr sur youtube marine le
décidée par lionel jospin et jacques
agnès b sont sur youtube qui me dit un
dernier grand meeting c'est à arras dans
différentes les uns sous l'effet des
en france on a un système on vote par
elle assure l'égalité devant la loi de
chantier de la représentativité et de
micheau d'opinionway merci d'être resté
de la nation c'est à dire de la
à la règle quel bilan calamiteux sans
détruire la ruralité et nos paysans de
sera du sort de notre pays si emmanuel
confie ce que le pouvoir face à l'élite
quelques dizaines de milliers de voix
qui défend une conception poste national
années on voit bien que la
désertification
bah ça ça fait pas très présidentiel
sursaut national qui te redonnera fierté
impression de tension et de violence et
notre seul horizon démographique qui ont
ta grandeur c'est dimanche que nous
des longues soirées de ses amis ou de sa
de 62 ans et 42 annuités pour les eaux
au peuple de france lève toi contre et
toute la diversité
redevenions cette nation indépendante et
d'accord avec sa politique parce qu ils
qui peut changer est ce que là on est
ressourcement de notre nation autour des
jours la retraite ne doit pas être une
fameux débat d'entre deux tours à
mépris pour les faibles les fragiles
des banquiers des cabinets de conseil
alors marine le pen est en retard dans
d'entreprises comme celle de routiers
elle termine sa campagne dans son fief
pieuse déférence que nous portons à nos
pouvait dire après ce dernier meeting de
peuple de france l'heure est venue de te
marquant et de très durable quelque
tient le choc je monte un peu pour qu'on
meeting de mobilisation à arras pas
dédiabolisation a en partie fonctionner
fantastique biodiversité
monde
si les millions de français que je
utilise le mot barrage faire barrage à
français
été travaillé avec des experts des hauts
candidats qui peuvent être identifiés au
macron qui est présenté comme voulant
à dire rester en place le système se
j'ai rencontré des milliers de français
blanc le rouge ce drapeau tricolore
et ceux qui sont tentés par une stérile
état et en réalité quand on regarde le
de l'action politique c'est le sens
c'est essentiel nous mettrons en oeuvre
qu'il n'y a pas de fatalité et que si le
répond alors permettez moi de vous dire
finalement les candidats ne veulent plus
l'expression directe des citoyens qui
essentiellement le pouvoir d'achat parce
financer sérieux de son de son projet
tous les citoyens sans distinction
chirac il ya 20 ans
déchaînement du système prête à tout
donc il fallait rétablir son image
dire que ça ne peut pas arriver
américain nous indiquer le chemin il
la subissent dans leur quotidien
mafias ou des obscurantismes les autres
le pas de calais prise de parole à 18h45
auto-proclamée arrogante et
près entre valéry giscard d'estaing et
emblématiques des programmes des deux
aussi sur sur ces sujets là et puis par
dès le début de la campagne
de suite est ce que au lendemain du
notre révolution localistes de
soit la vision nationale
c'est vous qu'il veut contourner
souffre de la vie chère il souffre qu'il
ça c'est ce qu'elle a répété à de
représente avec quoi que ce soit à voir
macron devait par malheur être reconduit
quand vous avez la main qui tremble
fort qu'ils oeuvrent à la paix du monde
chose qu'on lui a répété pendant tout le
un monde nomade et liquides une vision
au compteur 600 milliards d'euros de
fraternité de l'unité de la générosité
ce que vous nous dites sont que des
aussi elle s'est déplacée ce matin avec
principes de la république tel qu'il
fonctionnaires des magistrats des chefs
marine le pen je vous dis quand même ce
déconstruire l'état détruire les
adressé aux indécis est ce qu'on peut
que j'ai vu tout à l'heure qui sont au
puisse bien voir marine le pen elle n'en
avec avec ses avec ses militants le
emmanuel macron elle se présente comme
l'affaiblissement terrible du pouvoir
massacrer les petits et les humbles par
et confiance
avec tant de mépris pour la nation
niveau au niveau local et puis le
famille
que vous êtes un peu trompé par rapport
mais l'écologie n'est pas la répression
l'issue de cette confrontation d'idées
écrirons ensemble les premières passes
pères et aux pères de nos pères il
d'origine de race ou de religion elle
n'a jamais été ouvert malgré le
nombreuses reprises contre emmanuel
pour sauver le soldat macro je sens un
drape de morale et bat le rappel des
quand vous hésitez dans une réponse ce
tout et tout est possible mais pour
lever et de te rassembler contre
abstentions je leur dis si vous n'allez
qui se sentait dans la ruralité dans les
que les thématiques de la sécurité de
d'une campagne électorale donc mais bien
vous pourrez donc suivre tout cela ici
souvenez-vous emmanuel macron a refusé
prendre de risque et à sur le coup ont
essayer d'acquérir l'image la plus
nous mèneront vers l' isolement il nous
moralisatrice nous sommes la voix est
sondages en la vérité elle aura lieu
peuple vote le peuple gagne je le dis
cathédrales soumise aux influences
nous sommes très plus que jamais à
avec l'extrême droite depuis le début de
dette supplémentaire et 400000 pauvres
développement des circuits courts pour
quinquennat et pendant toute la campagne
que nous portons quête une vision
plus de 600 milliards d'euros de dette
qu'il se passera demain parce qu on le
du fait des déconstructions brouillonne
nous voulons enfin que les français tous
le patriotisme économique
sentir ça que finalement c'est presque
des chauffeurs routiers vous la voyez
d'activité qui est aujourd'hui
résulte de sa loi fondamentale notre loi
françois mitterrand il ya eu des
son incompétence de transformer notre
cette image qui s'est adouci cette image
c'est un argument électoral
peut-on confier cinq ans de plus un
d'achat et surtout
services publics on est vraiment dans un
peu plus de 2 de temps de campagne ce
macron et le système finalement qu'il
d'entreprise et surtout il a été mûri
ce nouveau chapitre du grand récit
française
bord de l'abyme plombé par des
n'y ait pas d'égalité avec la métropole
d'ailleurs avec une absence de taille
à ce que vous m'avez dit avant avant
son exact contraire non qu'elle lui
et de l'humanité
a cure d'avoir deux d'avoir donné
2016 se rend compte que le vote s'est
fait un dernier déplacement remonte
concept de majorité silencieuse vous
mouvement populaire et gilet jaune nous
l'immigration sont des acquis nous front
cette nation qui nous a vu naître
je crois que les français sont mieux
dimanche soir comment elle peut faire la
le drapeau tricolore et de signes de
qui lactique qui peut qui peut porter et
sur figaro live mais avant d'écouter
éclopés de la politique la triste
l'interdiction de rouler de se chopper
mèneront vers la discorde et vers
espoir se lever dans tout le pays quand
permettre de produire et de consommer au
république sur maîtrise maîtrise ses
pernicieux de l'étranger qui ont laissé
et donc elle avait à coeur je crois de
des institutions locales les troisièmes
témoigne de notre détermination à
respecte toutes les croyances nous
présidentielle possible donc renvoyé
ou est ce que manuel macron a convaincu
troisième élément c'est qu'il faut
l'oligarchie qui n'a pour seule religion
c'est leur hausse leur responsabilité
campagnes dans les villes et les
qu'on attend d'un président de la
l'âme de la majorité silencieuse
pas la politique c'est la politique qui
qui s'est rapproché du peuple et puis
gouverner le pays pour le mener à la
suivra évidemment sur sur le figaro live
jusqu'au bout qu'on est là sans
avons-nous envie de confier notre pays à
le débat avec les autres candidats comme
qu'on avant de prendre l'antenne avant
jouer on est à deux jours et là il faut
représente depuis des années et lève toi
élections
l'impression d'avoir été peut-être battu
avez raison c'était intéressant qu'elle
supplémentaire et un déficit de notre
qu'il y aura une cinquantaine de jours
m'amène à la question de l'abstention on
français déjà milinaire que nous devons
balance commerciale en un gouffre sans
réglementations absurde des concurrences
fraternelle une société unie autour d'un
renvoie les arguments c'est à la fois le
fondamentale la constitution de la vème
république c'est de la clarté et une
absolument pas
de plus
national elle voulait élargir sa
marine le pen on analyse tout ça avec
l'étang d'art sacré dans les plis duquel
renseignés sur les enjeux fondamentaux
l'abyme nous ne voulons plus de la
si ça si ça arrive dimanche ce sera une
en détail hier soir mais on peut
les français est accès à une éducation
fait dans trois quatre états où le
lors de mes rencontres avec les français
plus près c'est cela la vraie écologie
disons plus classique le 53 47 de 2007
qui nous nourrit et que nous
dossiers on a marine le pen qui est en
villages et même dans la
président maintenant confié cinq ans
forcément tout risque et à haut risque
utilise ce terme est un concept qui a
absolument pas parler de la sécurité des
différence encore est ce que c'est
et a pris plus de voir oui voilà il a
défendre leur mémoire est donc notre
nous mettrons d'ailleurs en réflexion la
voulons une république indivisible
entre le deuxième tour de la
viendra à vous qui vous rattrapera avec
ribambelle d anciens premiers ministres
que le mondialisme la guerre incessante
instaurons une proportionnelle pour
emmanuel macron lui se rendra à figeac
trop de jeunes préfèrent tenter leur
prospérité retrouvée et à la confiance
par abandon des pouvoirs publics un
mobiliser montrer qu' on est toujours en
s'ils ne comptaient pas comme si les
hier je reviens sur ce billet data
locaux issus du savoir faire et du
notre liberté dans ce monde incertain et
symétrique et le contraire c'est ça qui
ou de louer son logement ce n'est pas de
fond reflet de notre déclassement et
cette volonté d'ouvrir son programme aux
un sentiment de sobriété de maîtrise de
va voter un sas est assez important
du choix de dimanche sur le bilan des
elles mêmes de monter dans le cas mais
corriger cette c'est cette erreur de
qu'on lance meeting de marine le pen
a souvent dit que l'abstention profiter
je vous vois tous
périurbanisation talent abandonnés par
sur le terrain sept avec vous c'est à
commerce extérieur record
qui qui peut l'aider à sortir du strict
déloyales organisé ou par le prix du
de s'effondrer ça se peut être ça la
mais même de gauche de gauche radicale
donné par cette alliance un marche pied
train d'arriver sur scène à arras c'est
été utilisé pour la première fois par le
capacité à prendre des décisions
république que nous devons au général de
chance ailleurs nous exonèrerons les
progressé de 2,8 points dont 21 pour
faire revivre pour nos enfants pour nos
état bienveillant qui assure aux
de qualité à la santé pour tous et
on va rester sur ces images parce que
français qui votent pour ces candidats
déficit d'infrastructures et surtout du
présidentielle et les élections
chaque français quelle que soit son
dans le lot mini meeting prévu dans le
est ça qui est vraiment intéressant dans
défaillant ou des présidentes des faits
course et que les indécis de toute façon
vous m'avez dit elle va rester
permettre à tous les courants même
migrations beaucoup parlé du du pouvoir
battront kivu maltraitera pour des
amis
en l'avenir
contrairement à eux nous aimons nous
courte vie des raisonnement comptable
de tous contre tous la saignée sociale
un système économique eco vertueux loin
vraie une vraie surprise et ça créera un
travail de nos producteurs bien sûr bien
histoire il est la marque de confiance
stratégie c'est alors ce sont davantage
une république où
comment on trouve un équilibre et
défigurer nos paysages et nos côtes avec
signe de notre décadence peuple de
alors c'est ça et puis ça ça rentre
mais au delà du bilan il y à son projet
imaginer peut-être une correction sur un
cet animal assez assez rigolote avant de
dangereux qui se dessine qui voudraient
savamment organisée savamment étudiée
thématiques socio-économique mais tout
et puis de l'autre côté marine le pen
scrutin était très serré à quelques
millier de quartier ces quartiers que ce
la majorité trop gentiment silencieuse
n'existait pas comme si toute
ça dimanche sa politique sa dimension
législatives
là l assemblée voilà être hésitante
quinquennat de brutalité qu'il a le
français à tous les français le respect
reconnaissance du vote blanc
président américain richard nixon en
je crois je ne me suis pas trompé
peuple de france l'heure est venue pour
bonsoir bonsoir quel est votre votre
probablement dans la même veine apaisé
c'est ce qu'elle peut faire là comme ce
origine quelle que soit sa religion quel
votre contact que j'ai affiné précisé
minoritaire d'être représentés à
possible et de conserver une forme
gaulle
moins de 30 ans d'impôt sur le revenu
manuels macron et sur le projet
pour nicolas sarkozy ça c'est vous me
ont fait leur choix est ce qu'on peut
l'état alors nous appuierons la
jeunes pour nos paysans pour nos
carburant qui rogne les dernières marges
comme la suppression des lits d'hôpitaux
au parti d'eric zemmour pour continuer à
compétences de calme de sang froid parce
ce dans ce duo qui est un duel
aussi en résonance avec son slogan quand
des risques que des gains donc il faut
oui c'est une donnée importante
un îlot macro nist cette ville d'arras
créneau
années encore à quoi sert-il de crier
qu'après si les français finalement
cent vous me dites au lendemain du
dizaines de milliers de voix près et un
soir à arras alors il est possible de
et le règne exclusive de la main
revenir sur sur le direct elle a mené
centre ville aux alentours de 15 heures
qui vise à construire un état
encore faire son choix est ce qu'il ya
partout à des salaires dignes à des
des éoliennes de 200 m dos l'écologie ça
déficit de vision que l'on doit avoir
que nous avons dans chacun des français
révérons nous chérissons
programmatique pas traiter uniquement de
l'assemblée nationale est de pouvoir s'y
afin qu'ils restent travailler au pays
nous en lacets et nous entraîner y
1969 dans un discours au peuple
point ou un autre peut-être un
toi de replacer la nation française au
france lève toi contre ceux qui
proposition alternative à sa politique
regret de ne pas être allé plus vite
notre république sera enfin résolument
d'achat et puis la dernière requête
de même elle a aussi ses limites et le
historique du rassemblement national si
au prétexte qu'ils pouvaient à certains
sondage du jour 56 44 pour emmanuel
la dignité et une protection sociale et
pen notamment pendant des années est ce
d'espérance que je pense
premier tour il était à 38 il est passé
dites cclat 51,8 voilà ce qui disons le
précédent alors qu'est ce qu'elle peut
certains se sont résignés à qualifier de
qu'est-ce qui les convainc qu'on démonte
il faut terminer avec le meilleur score
presque défensive a pas tout à fait du
que soit son patrimoine quelle que soit
revitalisation des campagnes par des
des gens qui vous disent j'hésite encore
des traités de libre-échange des super
fragiles pour nos aînés pour nos
indécise et ça l'a pénalisé soit elle
on ne peut pas être chef de l'état sion
le peuple vote le peuple gagne il l
et sa personnalité
renforcer ce projet
sap petits français
le faire exister dans la vie politique
peu comme le 21 avril 2002 il ya 20 ans
d'enthousiasmé et de ce point de vue là
avec 600 personnes
tout simplement parce que marine le pen
resserrer ce rapport de force quand nous
invisible des marchés sans visage sans
n'est pas jeux précédents pas retrouvé
que c'est encore le cas est ce que si
évidemment mais on voit bien que chacun
exprimer
partout macron d'émission pendant trois
compris vers le pire parce que nous
pour ces shibo territoire cette grande
différemment disons surtout vu la
lui il n'a pas fait campagne
une campagne si je veux dire frédéric
logements décents à des transports de
ses sujets qui sont les thèmes
bienveillant
une majorité que j'appelle à donner de
faire pour essayer de de resserrer ce
le programme des autres et qu'on
dans les sondages a absolument il y en a
approfondissement et pourquoi pas une
méprisent dans la famille l'enracinement
ne méritait aucune considération comme
américain et il opposait la maj la
d'abord nous défendrons le principe de
vous nous rejoignez ont débrayé ce
sociale
front républicain
attendues un endroit vous pourrez suivre
premier rang des puissances de la faire
moments parfois être vide nous ne
que c est associée à la dimension
essayer d'éviter la
artisans pour tous ceux qui concourent à
samaa si on sait que c'est quand même
sa ville son village coupe protection et
c'est aussi l'une des fonctions d'un
les gens s'abstiennent ce week-end ça
délaissent les réalités la vie des gens
incitations fiscales à l'installation ou
score classique c'est entre 51 et 53 ans
physique à tous les moments de la vie ce
macron d'accord on va pouvoir analyser
les images qui ont disparu mais on va
classiques du rassemblement national
territoires perdus de la république
tanker super polluants loin de
car ce plongeur
quoi qu'on en dise a produit encore des
le but du rassemblement national
reconstruire l'état parce que c'est le
explique que les autres ça ne peut pas
avait aujourd'hui sur le pupitre
les projets politiques vous savez mes
assez destruction profonde de l'état
emportera dans son cartable les mêmes
beaucoup entre 20 et 30% des personnes
dernier meeting de marine le pen qui
âme et sans frontières
cherche à se poser en s'opposant à
est arrivé deuxième dans cette ville
présidentielle là c'est un meeting vous
jours vous pouvez le congédier sans
qualité et pour nos compatriotes
sommes un grand et courageux peuple
il ne regrette ni ses grossièretés
rapport de force
et après avoir attendu si longtemps
d'un meeting la salle renvoi de
favorisera marine le pen alors pour
29 ans elle est restée à 20 d'accord
tout ça on va on va utiliser ces
la constance des liens de solidarité qui
plus que ce que j'ai vu en partie au
est trop agressive et en reproches
et les jeunes créateurs d'encre plus
nouvelle mesure mais mais là aussi il
c'est presque poétique
donc parler vraiment au sujet de
nous mettrons en oeuvre leur hic le
marcher ou au contraire et bien que
pour des constructions froide tiré de
à la transformation d'entreprises il ne
minorité bruyante d'accord c'est à dire
créer un effet d'entraînement pour pour
d'indépendance dans leur intelligence et
rayonner dans le monde par son histoire
respect amour et solidarité
selon elle le pilier de de la france
s'il était le détenteur d'une vérité
dans la préfecture du pas-de-calais avec
la nation abandonnent une partie de ses
la prospérité de la maison france en
s'est tenue ce soir à arras dans le pas
on a des écarts aussi aussi minime
voulons plus que les petites logique
en réalité ce projet il n'a qu'une seule
la voix en me donnant ses voix mes amis
notre constitution le gouvernement du
revenir à arras en direct vous me disais
c'est évidemment de tuer dans l'oeuf
l'autre c'était très clair hier soir
absolument et alors peuple lève toi
ça c'est ici sur fear alive et puis
l'économie mondialisée tout le monde
chers amis le nôtre comme celui d'
débat qui pose de vision les nationaux
d'outre-mer anne au courant c'est quand
chiffres pour pouvoir analyser le
qu'elle n'exprime pas son programme soit
peuple de france lève toi lève toi
caractérisée hier soir ne serait ce pas
donc très très peu de variation pour
politique sociale sera financé grâce au
effets et et continue de mobiliser une
qui ne sont pas sûrs d'accord de lors de
l'instant notre indice de participation
81,8 mitterrand fait 54 jacques chirac
avoir à demander la permission nous nous
chances d'accession savoir à l'éducation
envers les non vaccinés ni la baisse des
l'énergie et de la confiance à la
enfants à la pauvreté à la misère à la
parce que nous sommes un peuple de
faut éviter à tout prix le caractère
refusant le débat d'idées pourtant
moins alors on voit bien qu'il ait trois
finalement mon programme est le meilleur
préoccupation des français
cette nouvelle formation et et et de
nous unissent qui ont méthodiquement
emmanuel macron ne sont pas qu'un
malheureuse le le déplacement de
pour qu'ils ont ici cela france
marine le pen elle se déplacera une
elle reste digne elle exprime ses idées
de calais 45 minutes de discours avec
courbant l'échiné en silence depuis des
24 % derrière emmanuel macron alors même
les élections législatives parce que ce
dont elle peut être chic pierre par le
intermédiaires la disparition des
dobbs économique ou idéologique ses
celles qui s'opposaient à la guerre du
c'est à dire que ça sous-entend qu'il
révélée que personne ne pouvait
marine le pen
meeting qui arrive on va on va
elle est latente et de de leur faire
s'agit plus seulement comme le dit le
donc on avait vraiment c'est cette
collectivement dans leur sagesse
référendum d'initiative citoyenne nous
peuple de france peuple de france le
s'établit à 72 % à 28 % d'abstention
ça ça la ramener à ce qu'était le
sera gagnant avec notre politique
partis d'ailleurs dans ce discours il ya
dernière fois elle dans la somme à
peuple par le peuple et pour le peuple
mais elle est jugée trop molle les
et les mondialistes les partisans de la
mémoire et de fidélité nous savons que
partie des français une fois de plus
ambition vous servir le projet que nous
et je développe mon programme faut faire
nécessaire en démocratie c'est avec une
dynamisme d'un projet qui fera des choix
catalogue de mesures derrière les
d'improvisation de ce type d'annoncé qui
leur choix je rappelle qu'au premier
une tonalité un peu différente de ce
est couché donc qu'ils aient dominé et
détruit notre héritage social en
même la moindre des choses en 2022 à car
ce millier de quartier échappent
proverbe de remettre l'église au milieu
contre ceux qui ont bradé ton industries
apl ni son mépris pour les 5 millions
à l'excellence à la promotion sociale et
campagne qui se passe mal et au
oui donc la troisième partie la dernière
opposition la traite à forte avec
qui paraît compliquée pour marine le pen
soir il reste il reste ce soir et reste
l'empêcher de se développer parce que
les français sont un grand peuple à des
électorale à vos militants donc vous
candidate c'est une question que je
aujourd'hui opposition de personnalités
s'intéresser à la prise de parole de
statuts des diplomates la disparition du
d'aménagement du territoire les
vietnam et la majorité silencieuse qui
détresse d'une vie qui ressemble
nouveau elle reste dans le nord une
français sont hypocrites voilà ce que
contester sans subir ces moqueries et
voilà mes chers compatriotes mes amis
que le pas de calais est complètement
jospin et jean marie le pen il y a vingt
génie scientifique et technique qui a
certitudes qui imprègne les milieux
une première partie introductive qui
cela elle a parlé des institutions
décennies
il n'ya pas de peuple plus adulte et
économiques industrielles énergétiques
partie une grande partie de mobilisation
les deux et il faut agir il faut faire
permettront à 500 mille citoyens de
contraire jeté toutes ses forces pour
grandes orientations transparaît
qui ont regardé avec un sourire
voulais vous poser avant qu'on organise
fébrilité étonnante que le président
sont en concurrence directe proximité
aujourd'hui à l'autorité républicaine
tour
qu'on a pu voir à perpignan avant le
qui doit désormais cesser s'extraire de
effectivement des accents de gauche
protection et l'étonnant de la
du village il s'agit de remettre aussi
l'ouvrant au monde entier qui ont fait
opposition de style dans le débat
c'est de récupérer des voix autour
nous dit gabriel sûr sur youtube c'est
terre qui lui est acquise près
score excellent pour françois mitterrand
là où flotte le drapeau français souffle
acquis à sa cause après 39 % pour marine
peuples les plus admirées un peuple qui
finalement davantage à la survie
réussi à attirer au moins dans les
devez d'une certaine manière à avoir un
qui qui l'aspect vous l'avait dit et
marine le pen que peut-elle faire pour
17% des électeurs se sont décidés le
peuple de france lève toi pour donner
ans d écart aussi faible et bien sont
financiers ou lens reçoit qui dirige
demain jusqu'à minuit pour pour faire
c'est un petit peu plus d'abstention que
quatre cent mille chômeurs ni la
fait sa prospérité pendant des siècles
campagnes évidemment qu'ils vont
marine le pen elle veut montrer un bel à
elle a pris cette ligne depuis plusieurs
premier tour de ce qu'on a pu voir à
pour les plus récents à l'assimilation
statut des préfets tous ces hauts
d'abbeville peu d'informations pour
les deux il faut évidemment
était une sorte de débrief du débat
c'est un fait un fait qu'il nous faut
déréglementation se déroule dans toutes
toujours la véritable philosophie qui
ses anathèmes
avec cette anaphore peuple de france
ce que nous disent les internautes sur
politiques que les français et j'ai
présentons aux français est une honda la
satisfait des centaines d'usinés être
était censé le soutenir et depuis c'est
pour construire la mobilisation
provoquer une consultation soit pour
innovants et performants mais aussi par
d'elle elle a dit et je redonne bardella
candidat a daigné s'y mettre on l'a vu
ton plus plus offensif plus violents et
avignon où elle avait commencé avec des
renverser la table vous réagissez vous
a suggéré le monde de sa lumière de sa
notamment et opposition de deux visions
intentions de vote on verra si ça se
l'école au milieu du village la mairie
assez marqué oui on a bien senti marine
les grandes lignes de ce que je ferais
des mères célibataires des veuves et des
campagne et donc faire des annonces
suppression de l'sf non il regrette de
comme un signe de fébrilité oui ou comme
idéologique et programmatique qui était
pas la créativité sans limites de ses
et tout le monde se dit tous les
connaître par notre plan 2d
fonctionnaires ayant vocation à être
vrai que marine le pen à un dilemme on
l'instant mais on sera là évidemment
j'en ai assez comme vous de cet
le chat et vous continuez à nous à
le vent de l'histoire et de la liberté
années 1 d'ailleurs c'est un peu le
républicaine
le pen au premier tour contre 25 pour
électorale de dimanche marine le pen qui
d'abord parler soit
cette de cette domination pour aller
dans la marge d'erreur et ne peuvent pas
les démocraties du monde il est normal
jour même
lors du premier tour et ça ce qui change
l'a répété ce matin le président du
un concept qui a fait florès et qui est
les sous-tendent la conception qu'ils
transforme effectivement dimanche dans
aujourd'hui notre pays la loi de la
vie à ce nouveau rêve français que nous
nouveau posée vocation le meeting est ce
métropolisation un nouvel essor et
ce besoin de montrer que lé plus
discours très positif là là tout de
confiance dans leur capacité à
dans le cadre d'une éducation qui
promouvoir une noix soit pour abroger
france à la france que l'on aime il est
j'ai été la première à parler du pouvoir
un signe de sauve qui peut vous entendez
analystes les observateurs de l'époque
lève toi c'est l'embrouillé clé 1 2 du
posez vos questions sur les différents
traiter
puis c'est aussi ce que j'ai appelé tout
dix voiliers jusqu'à la dernière limite
au milieu du village
marteler son message en espérant
si les français me font confiance et
rassemblement national qu'il n'y aurait
générosité et même de son engagement
être détectées par par les outils des
très forte donc il faut essayer de
des économies sur les dépenses
demain remplacés par des courtisans
jeunes générations prolétarisés les
contre-pied de 2017 et on l'a bien vu
délocalisés pendant que des millions de
le pen qui essayait de passer elle l'a
emmanuel macron on sait que c'est un
de projets donc là elle a vraiment
perdre ses nerfs
des ghettos liée à une immigration
demain matin merci fade avec messieurs
devrait à strasbourg de dunkerque à
repris par toute une série de deux
enfants par sa langue la plus belle
par rapport à 2002 c'est ça qui est ça
parler de son programme avancer son
chat sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr on
se disent que c'est un coup dont jacques
retrouver la vie des citadins aussi qui
ne pas être allé assez vite
pas d'alliance avec eric zemmour on ne
ont de l'homme et du monde la vision
s'extraire des manipulations grossières
construirons dès demain unis dans la
démocrates presque qu emmanuel macron
était ce matin dans dans la somme à roye
les commerces et les lieux les services
que c'est devenu la valeur sûre de
pour aller voter et puis il ya aussi
les urnes les électeurs de jean luc
une loi chacun sera à nouveau consultés
d'achat
réduire au maximum un rival potentiel
suite attaqué symptômes peut-être de ce
restera nationale et dont je n'accepte
à l'heure le débrief et du débat c'est
irrespect permanent je serai quant à moi
utiliser des arguments sans queue ni
injustifiées ou nocives de l'état
souvent répété comme la candidate du bon
écarte emmanuel macron je le répète il
jungle que les mondialistes veulent
nommé par le fait du prince des salariés
de m'avoir accompagné merci à vous merci
hier soir dans l'est dans le débat avec
donc c'est à dire quasiment en arrivant
plastic bertrand dans cette salle darras
change par rapport à 2002 et juillet
nouveaux damnés de la terre qui ont mis
pour la liberté souvent jusqu'au
un acte d'amour et de respect amour de
département qui lui est cher à marine le
anarchique incontrôlée on est passé aux
sondages là là on est sur un rapport de
aller plus républicaine c'est on lave
marine le pen alors qu'on la sent
mélenchon on attend donc marine le pen
convaincre le plus grand nombre
instaurer nous n'en voulons pas la prime
cherche surtout pas à aller parler à
scrutin de dimanche pour elle faire en
si emmanuel macron son était préoccupé
familles françaises ont été jetés dans
cherché à
chirac aura beaucoup de mal à se relever
imaginez un peu ce que pourrait être un
marseille de fort-de-france à cayenne
à julien qu'une elle aussi qui est en
langue du monde qui en a fait la patrie
que le peuple est à l'arbitré
fierté la fraternité l'ardeur patriotes
essaye d'y répondre frédéric on est au
programme de façon positive mais montrer
cette part de mobilisation électorale ne
à s'affranchir du prêt-à-penser qu'une
2002 il ya vu un vrai sursaut civique au
sens avec cette démonstration que
tête
qu'il porte pour les décennies qui
qu'il s'est passé hier soir dans ce dans
dans l'isoloir le jour même d'accord
avant l'entrée généralement de marine le
cette volonté de rester sobre la
ou trois mille personnes sont attendues
aussi une façon de bien justement de de
les filets jaunes par milliers sur les
marine le pen qu'on attend d'une minute
peut-être un peu plus en difficulté dans
pen avec hénin beaumont cette ville dont
personnalités deux candidats et
pas qu'elles soient démantelés par des
d'électeurs alors quand même je vais
d'ici un catastrophisme qui n'a
profiteront très vite du désengorgement
sacrifice nous voulons qu'il en soit à
nous réhabiliterons la valeur travail
plus blanc que blanc quoi il faut le
de mckinsey y iront représenter la
qui devrait s'exprimer d'une minute à
force qui est quand même beaucoup plus
écoutée respectée
je n'aurais pas eu à le faire
la misère se voyait arracher leur
la présidente du respect des français et
sorte que sa base électorale se
souligner tous les contrastes entre les
lendemain du débat est ce qu'on peut
notre pays respect de notre peuple
demain vous djouad nouméens c'est sur
exactement à l'été avec avec des
zones de non droit lc riche et ce sans
régie c'est grâce à lui que vous avez pu
premier tour c'est le record
eric zemmour avant le premier tour alors
les débats est-ce que vous avez d'autres
viennent la mienne ma vision politique
ronds-points de nos campagnes avant de
ce débat je vous n'êtes pas psy je sais
répéter le marteler non je ne suis pas
pen on va suivre ce meeting dans un
puisque emmanuel nacre on a voulu
à l'autre dans cette salle darras pour
des villes avec des loyers moins chers
donc voilà au delà de 53 quand un
être un peu piquant
des plus grands artistes écrivains et
n'y a pas de faits de fatalité encore
soit dans l'isoloir soir
l'autre dans cette salle darras pour son
du plus fort appliquée partout et à tous
france à l'étranger ou gérer nos
recrutements établissement par
d'abstention parce que j'aime tout
qui seul nous rendre à la force et le
sobriété étant vu comme un atout de
voir ce meeting ce soir on suit la fin
cohorte de tristes sires temps de leur
ce soir une dizaine de minutes marine le
emmanuel macron est déconnecté ça c'est
notamment donc c'est vraiment un un
les avantages de son programme en
cesse de le répéter c'est un vrai enjeu
absolument aucun sens il nous a accusés
elle a fait son fief lé député du pas de
qu'on imagine qu'au deuxième tour ils
camionneurs vous voyez ces images ici de
mobilisent le plus possible et donc il
et lui je serai la présidente du pouvoir
dont le délaissement par les pouvoirs
attachement à nos valeurs à commencer
exemples de personnalités politiques
par rapport aux sondages en france sa
je suis frappé je suis frappé par la
dignité et pleurait d'orange en voyant
tous les continents trois couleurs à le
prendre la parole lors de son dernier
je sais qu'ils attendent désespérément
regard dit voilà parce qu'il ya un peu
les réprimer avec une brutalité sans
voir une inflexion sondagière déjà ce
établissement
répondre de manière plus plus vive à
instant alors de quoi doit elle parle et
réduire ce rendez-vous à référendum
ferme aujourd'hui pour certaines zones
nouveau ainsi pour les siècles qui
seront probablement obligé de le faire
départements le projet d' atteinte au
pour dimanche prochain la plupart des
et donc des surfaces plus grandes des
deux projets pour mobiliser ses
moins de résultats acquis d'avancé
très bien que vous êtes sondeurs mais si
dangereuse elle l'a encore fait ce soir
nous ferons confiance aux enseignants et
présidentialité de montrer une maîtrise
une vraie stratégie elle a parlé de
dernier grand meeting de campagne
peut être par le passé qu'il n'était
nous n'en voulons pas
de vouloir des vacciner les français
meeting de campagne en suisse assure sur
du bureau de vote et oui après après des
poètes
servir
de culpabilité mais beaucoup et puis il
est profondément
courage de rebâtir notre pays le plus
pen devrait prendre la parole
successifs à décourager tant d'énergie
président et est réélu ou élu avec une
par la liberté
au 2e tour après le deuxième tour pour
qu'on peut voir une différence alors pas
on fait un peu de psychologie il ya ça
d'achat je serai la présidente de votre
valise jamais eu lieu mais aux états
du respect mais en réalité l'attitude
précédent pas peu de france lève toi
banco la question sera finalement assez
calais elle est conseillère
de la campagne sur figaro live on suit
oui alors ça aussi c'est une des clés du
son déplacement matinal qui n'était pas
plus fort dans tel ou tel domaine est ce
s'effondrer les perspectives d'avenir de
à nos écoles pour revivifier ce creuset
fille et fils de france
de non france
viennent alors peuple de france
transports désaturer des embouteillages
on sait que l'air soit il voulait parler
détaillant les points de faiblesse de
sondages même la totalité des sondages
électeurs à ses électeurs et son
cette majorité silencieuse qui serait
des dossiers et et de ne pas donner le
fille or alive jolivet vert sur youtube
le sacrifice de l'intérêt général au
départementale depuis l'an dernier ex
honnêtement frédéric est ce qu'on y
comme si ça voulait dire quelque chose
sincèrement humaniste elles placent
il n'est pas de plus beau nom que le nom
rapport de forces que nous mesurons
ya une campagne de deux d'entre deux
on a essayé de voir où elle pouvait
pour l'instant on l'avait très bien vu
nous parierons le flou migratoires
unis on a quand même le précédent 2016
le travail doit être reconnue et le
les derniers déplacement demain on a
du pouvoir d'achat en premier le tirage
que ce soir c'est une valeur refuge
deux mains si vous allez voter si vous
forcément prévu il a souvent surpris
croit encore dans le camp de marine le
gagner les législatives
emmanuel mâcon macro et de l'attaqué 1
peuple de france
de fatalité l'a répété à plusieurs
pouvoir d'achat j'ai fait des
leurs enfants
beau pays du monde peuple de france lève
résorber une pollution diminue et
aujourd'hui et au delà de la marge
la donnent battue et donc on sait quel
mois de campagne donc les deux candidats
marge de 2 55 et et au delà c'est
la rassure et ça l'a débridé et on se
dénigrer c'est intéressant ça oui alors
évidemment le grand le grand la grande
presse pour marine le pen alors oui il
bénéfice des intérêts particuliers nous
de l'harmonie sociale tout comme nous
électorat et toujours on le sent chez
conseillère régionale c'est son
simple maquereau ou la france et
en 2010 est le débat avait eu lieu
second tour et du vote qu'elle doit
peuple de france lève toi lève toi
reprises
pen ou est ce qu'on se dit et on
tours qui est très intense sur sur le
propositions très puissante et très
marine le pen en allant se déplacer sur
alors il ya ce que elle joue pas sur
au sort lui a été favorable elle a parlé
récupérer les dernières voient ce
filles et fils du peuple de france
massifs et anarchie qui ajoute sans
l'heure est venue l'heure est venue pour
ceux de celui de de son adversaire ou de
lève-toi reprend confiance des fortes
qu'aucun résultat net acquis d'avancé
d'erreur la marge d'erreur c'est 1,3 à 3
l'homme
sentiment d'un caractère
département d'ancrage on va suivre donc
ya beaucoup de candidats qui sont qui
chez marine le pen cette volonté de
je resterai chez moi le débat ne m'a pas
ou le discours c'est quand même aussi de
c'est une vraie stratégie c'est aussi
de france le pays des français
demande presque il a fallu attendre ce
travail doit payer nous offrirons elle
conte confiance à notre fonction
autour de la participation électorale
n'en voulons pas pas cette élection nous
concret sur ce sujet crucial tant sur la
vraiment un bon score sous la vème
de ça elle n'a pas forcément été
qu'elle doit susciter s'est levé tous
soirée de dimanche avec vincent roux
en raison de faire campagne jusqu'à
mercredi de la deuxième semaine de
pourrait avoir une forme de victoire
la république indivisible
est le vôtre aujourd'hui on peut le
deux tableaux à la fois il faut sauver
qu'elles pouvaient faire essayer de
les familles la famille des familles
cesse de nouveaux problèmes et il le
brillante à ce moment elle va quand même
contre ceux qui ont vendu à la découpe
rassurer je vois un message sur youtube
vous levez nous serons au pouvoir
le terrain un peu au dernier moment
puis ce slogan qu'elle ne cesse de
débat pour trouver ce biais d' attaques
répéter pour ça que c'est sympa mais 6%
dans la défaite en limitant la casse et
république est-ce que ce soir on peut
agité exubérant comme cela avait pu être
le discours de marine le pen frédéric
ont été plus à l'aise dans un format que
jusqu'à la dernière minute et de
convaincu voilà ce que ce que nous dit
publique la haute administration comme
une de ses zones de force quand on
mais même quand on reprend toutes les
points on voit qu emmanuel macron 56% en
toi d'aller demander des comptes à tous
avec bruno dray on suivra tout ça et
les fleurons de notre prospérité
jouer au maximum l'effet de contraste
l'histoire la présidentielle et essayer
parfois emmanuel macron lui ils étaient
renverser la tendance même si ce ne sont
mais aussi la république est laïque
l'entre-deux tours comme cette année et
pour emmanuel macron donc 44% pour pour
les tous les verrous essayer d'atténuer
soigne chaque jour davantage la
insisté ça c'est son axe de campagne le
contre emmanuel macron sa personnalité
chercher à convaincre à convaincre les
imaginer marine le pen parler du voile
baisse des dépenses contraintes que sur
qu'est la nation nos enfants aucun d'un
en ayant un score proche de celui
ont passé défends ton présent et surtout
répéter depuis plusieurs jours quand le
élections présidentielles il ya eu des
pour cela aussi
micheau vous reste avec moi on écoute
d'antoine qui dit les gens ne se rendent
cette cet internaute
regarde l'image qu'on parrainer des deux
que des sondages mais ce sont des
de l'emporter en parlant aux électeurs
alors peuple de france l'heure est venue
d'emmanuel makoun sa j'ignore ce qu'ils
les fonctionnaires de tous échelons qui
le mercredi elle était à 40 % marine le
en banlieue parisienne à saint denis il
puis on se retrouve très vite excellente
le cas lors du débat 2010 est
pouvoir d'achat proche des gens c'est
nationale alstom lafarge technique
l'augmentation des salaires et des
perspective d'une assimilation réussie
l'opposition entre le programmes des
élections présidentielles avant celle ci
pas compte de la gravité d'une le pen au
mitterrand ses débuts à la télévision
sondages qui ne lui sont pas favorables
on a beaucoup parlé à ce débat c'était
indécis alors un meeting vrai qu'on
peuple vote le peuple gagne qui est
les craintes et pour cela montrer que un
de jean luc mélenchon et puis ensuite
marine le pen on est au delà de la marge
aux entreprises un environnement
dans l'histoire de la vème république et
vraiment ce sur quoi insiste m oui et je
tous que 10e marine le pen et puis à la
prenant la marge d'erreur maximum trois
dimanche départ tout navire vive la
candidats elle a un avantage c'est
par exemple ou est ce que ce sont des
soirée et à bientôt sur figaro live
ceux qui tombent et pisé et leur dire en
conformément à notre constitution
projet que j'ai voulu pour tous au coeur
pensions que sur des protections
généralement la participation est plus
effectivement un changement de stratégie
pouvoir elle le répète nous aussi on
est arrivé en début d'après-midi pour
pen les dans les intentions de vote elle
parler aux électeurs d'eric zemmour
servent avec un dévouement admirable
est-ce qu'on peut aussi essayer de
d'erreur on sait que ces sondages
vraiment un appel à la mobilisation à la
parle davantage sa base électorale
de te lever peuple de france
sujets sur lesquels elle s'est empêtrée
économique fiscale et juridique
qu'elle comprend mieux les
en matière de sécession des territoires
se disent entre eux dans leur dos leur
manuels macron et son programme à l
du coeur de la femme et de la mère que
fin du discours à la fin du meeting on
sociales supplémentaires
c'est un équilibre difficile j'imagine
la laïcité républicaine sera réaffirmée
points qui seraient à 53% donc compliqué
des 2e tour
l'état et donc le pays par leur
avait perdu deux points entre le
vote le pen n'est pas un vote risque et
sans doute le point d'orgue de sa
préparer l'avenir les élections à venir
pense que la raison de le faire c'est la
préoccupations des citoyens
face vous nous avez trompés vous nous
fera de l'écologie non je ne veux pas
dans la toute dernière ligne droite
participation de ses électeurs on va
peuvent avoir un effet de démobilisation
nous soutiendrons les familles
mercredi et le vendredi donc de 40 à 38
très à l'aise avec le format classique
psychologie on voit bien que les les
c'est l'idée de garder l'enthousiasmé
pour l'instant les électeurs d'eric
quel est l'écart moyen alors c'est
je suis et demain si vous le décidez à
protecteur nous garantiront un
forte au second tour qu'au premier c'est
entre la personnalité des manuels macron
analyse tout ça et on essaie de
donc elle a rappelé la constitution elle
il ne suffit plus seulement de regretter
discriminer j'ai trop souffert et de vie
campagne c'est la candidate par nom qui
elle est davantage en prise avec sa volt
zemmour se reportent massivement dit
donc pour l'instant c'est encore cet
monoparentales française et feront des
et notamment l'élection législative on a
permanence par leur neutralité par leur
campagne électorale pourquoi parce que
campagnes électorales ce sont des
reprendre tout ça dans l'ordre vous
commenter pour voir si marine le pen a
peut-être difficile à établir comme ça
de la quatrième république c'est un
doit elle doit préciser sa pensée ou
normal parce que c'est le tour décisif
des mobilisations par certitude de la
c'est là une condition de la
partir de mai prochain au coeur de la
elle-même j'ai trop souffert de mon nom
et sa propre personnalité voilà le
ça donnerait le sentiment d'une grande
patriotisme économique qui nous fera
à travers ces images d' enthousiasme
a rappelé l'article 1 de la constitution
est jugée la plus crédible en matière de
moments très particuliers ou ou parfois
mais c'est plutôt serré à partir de
avez abandonnés vous nous avez des
% puis on se souvient qu'elle avait fini
la communautarisation comme l'a fait
est lavé le cerveau sondages
vu que jean luc mélenchon s'était
n'hésitez pas vous réagissez sur youtube
celui ont choisi mais généralement enfin
accord loin du compte le salut mélanie
homme de la quatrième république c'est à
évidemment le débat de 2017 a été un
essayer de s'en détacher
fébrilité quand une grande agitation ce
personnes en situation de handicap et du
changé la donne est ce qu'elle sera plus
ce nom c'est une marque c'est une marque
qu'elle a qu'à la cité elle a beaucoup
jean marine le pen on est à quasiment
conscience professionnelle
tranquillité civile à laquelle je suis
immiscé dans la campagne il ya deux
défaite c'est à dire des électeurs qui
décision publique ap c'est pourquoi il
président sortant sans rien faire mais
préférer les entreprises françaises dans
surdoué de la finance est un cancre par
dire le meeting le banquet républicain
encore plus bas le jour du second tour
vous nous posez vos questions vos
d'intentions de vote c'est une proximité
du québec bon soir même au québec à
ils sont les garants de la liberté des
pouvoir d'achat et le pouvoir d'achat
alors c'est un c'est un élément c'est
le président il ya trois exceptions 65
jours en disant je postule pour être
quand on pourra dire ah c'était une
d'énergie de confiance c'est de façon
classes et vous nous avez ruiné et
90% d'accord donc ça c'est fait il n'y a
statut des aidants si dévoués et si
offensif plus agressive que ce qu'elle a
se disent que les jeux sont faits que ça
réactions sur lefigaro.fr également je
débat manquer ce qu'on appelle un acte
élection serrée et marine le pen
les marchés publics et nous poussera à
particulièrement soucieuse
serait sans doute mal compris et est
c'est la première préoccupation des
qui est parfois difficile à porter mais
le meeting c'était quelqu'un qui était
premier ministre est-ce que ça aussi ça
exemple on n'avait pas forcément entendu
montréal on vous regardera et on sait
d'agir agir enfin
parlé de l'outre-mer aussi bref elle a
avec avec les lecteurs et d'ailleurs
citoyens et de la concorde civile avec
finalement est devenu et le
là pour l'instant aujourd'hui pas de
vous lis je transmets à frédéric micheau
lourd en terme de communication c'est à
pas deux il n'y a pas de difficulté de
c'est la première puisque on ignore
indirecte tenter de convaincre ces
évidemment contre-productif hoffmeyer
désormais c'est à nous de vous congédié
là elle a l'air de s'en servir alors
pu detry hier soir on suit tout ça sur
les accompagner dans l'exportation
indispensable un axe fort de mon
ce genre de phrase je voulais venir un
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde notamment qui
il ne s'agit pas d'attenté à une liberté
peut être une question que se posent
ne sert à rien de se déplacer pour aller
nous mettrons un terme communautarisme
français donc c'est vraiment elle qui
c'est un trait d'image qui qui qui a
un excellent orateur mais à la
ont suivi le débat hier soir chez nous
ce point de vue là pourquoi est ce qu'il
encore comment l'élection fonctionne 69
je veux quand même qu'on commence
dire quelque chose qui est très visible
véritable infections inflexion v on
voter c'est aussi contre ça que marine
rassemblement national est devenu
essayé de voir justement l'outre-mer je
peu plus tard mais lynette sur youtube
les temps davantage sensibiliser à
quinquennat et
marine le pen après c'est une question
c'est une marque donc c'est les
frédéric avec cette attitude très
indécis renvoyant une image d'optimisme
ne veut pas nouer des alliances d'abord
parce que c'était difficile de le suivre
est le plus entrer en résonance avec les
moi il n'y aura plus de différence entre
qui nous dit une marine le pen plus
télévision il était figé il était il
presque un parti de gouvernement capable
la liberté pratiquer son culte quel que
verra demain mais quand on regarde les
beaucoup progressé et al'inverse
me dit je suis de gauche et je voterai
parce que la fiche exclut la gauche
avantages et les inconvénients d'une
ou au gangstérisme qui ont fini par
parce que le score du premier tour est
quand on est à l'étranger elle dit
veux qu'on en parle pourquoi l'outre-mer
de rivaliser tout prêt d'emmanuel
agressif cela donne celle de 2017 et
le pen doit lutter sport s'est pour sa
offensive envers emmanuel macron j'ai
marque les avantages c'est que elle est
premiers indicateurs et qu'on demande
sans aucun complexe madame le pen je
l'intérêt économique national cessera
les français
était glacée par la télévision l'a
et de mobilisation le discours de marine
attentes des français attendent qu'on
emmanuel macron paraît effectivement un
alain poher c'est le centre centre
c'est intéressant on sait pour qui a
trois fois supérieur rassemblement
soit le culte liberté à laquelle nous
j'ai trop souffert mes chers amis
part donc elle a dit à plusieurs
transformer le grand manteau unis de la
ensuite il a fait beaucoup de progrès on
qu'elle aurait aimé voir une marine le
matheron à partir quelques chiffres ce
aux français qui a le plus convaincu
très bien identifiés sur l'échiquier
c'était ridicule voilà ce que ce qu'elle
reprises que rien n'est fait qu'il n'y a
d'être spoliateurs pour être protecteur
voté l outre-mer au premier tour oui
le pen 45 minutes environ combien vous
plusieurs phrases un con qu'on peut
peu plus éloigné de du quotidien des
pen plus agressive hier soir je lui
gauche le versus pompidou toute la
national fait trois fois plus de voix
qui sont exacerbées par la situation
suis un peu provocateur mais c'est un
serait un score honnête alors je crois
sommes par respect pour les croyants par
france en une peau de léopard
a on a comme ça quelques cas de figure
nous dit donc peut-être en effet autant
moi-même d'injustice et de persécution
dans ce débat emmanuel macron 41% marine
aussi marc marco comme d'habitude les
pour jean luc mélenchon de façon très
qu'on peut retrouver un président ne
que le parti d'eric enfin que la
pas de facile de face et de fatalité
m'avez dit que 26 minutes c'est un
discours du npa qu'on a entendu ce soir
gauche machores refuse d'aller voter
politique marquée très connu qui est
respect pour notre histoire par respect
avec des personnalités qui étaient
cessera d'être un censeur pour être un
économique la hausse des prix de
face aux mafieux croyez moi ma volonté
rester ce soir sur ce meeting dont vous
devrait pas se tenir comme cela elle
médias entonne le refrain de marine a
me souvenir de mémoire que la moyenne
en raison du nom que je portais pour que
certain 6 minutes voilà un discours
large alors pourquoi elle en parle
pardon qu'il faut qu'il faut se
puis il ya deux ans et il ya 2012 allait
très anti capitaliste est presque
français on sait aussi que le pouvoir
l'énergie l'inflation d'une hier général
pour nos principes républicains attachés
parlait de l'attitude d' emmanuel macron
assez courts près que marine le pen a
d'abord parce que je pense qu'elle a un
prenons un cas très récent peut-être
déjà perdu non ce n'est pas ce qu'on dit
allez voir les premières images avec
doit être 50 entre 55 et 57 d'accord
facilitateur
très mobilisatrice pour des électeurs
isole dents c'est toujours le cas ça
de fléchir apport ma main ne tremblera
étonnant alors on a senti ces dernières
chef de l'état je puisse athlètes ne
hier soir elle a visé à de très
vrai lien avec avec l'autre mère donc je
mobiliser et toute cette anna fort de
il s'agit concrètement de prévenir ou
été très offensive contre emmanuel
marine le pen qui devrait s'exprimer aux
voter j'ai l'impression que la wii en
enfin
on essaye d'analyser en explique les
emblématique celui de valérie pécresse
serait ce qu'une seconde n'a moindre
qui sont des fidèles du du rassemblement
pas mais la république indivisible ce
semaines la à tendance sociale
alentours de 18h45 comme elle l'a fait
nous voulons
nombreuses reprises elle a saupoudré son
sondages mais en effet elle peut
pense il ya une part une part de
2010 est en réseau le scénario là ça
réprimer les tentations de petits
macron avec toujours ce clivage on sait
et c'est vrai qu'il ya été assez
socialistes pressent comme le dit eric
discrimination je ne retirerai aucun
discours de ce qu'elle qualifie de
je veux miser sur la jeunesse cette
peut-être gagner on verra ça dimanche
la semaine dernière c'était avignon
peut arriver et c'est le scénario que
zemmour de marine le pen mais ce soir
groupes sectaires qui répandent le
critiqué sur sur la qualité de ses
comme elle l'a fait juste avant le
national et de le pen jean-marie puis
dédain chez emmanuel macron alors qu'on
c'était particulièrement fort dans
que emmanuel macron a répété à marseille
meetings notamment les années mais très
que nous mesurons aujourd'hui dans nos
soir je voudrais qu'on regarde ce qui
premier tour à perpignan elle a pris le
poison de l'islamisme et porte atteinte
doué en débat dans le débat face à face
l'ouest est très fort il y avait cette
s'est passé aujourd'hui parce que marine
et hier soir que ce deuxième tour était
marine ben non il ya une sorte de
intentions de l'auteur il reste encore
était ensemble la semaine dernière à
plus de cette forme de deux meetings
à la liberté de conscience de ceux y
le pen veut occuper le terrain mais mais
trois jours on s'attend pas un record
dimension effectivement anti capitaliste
avignon on a vu le le débat hier soir là
un référendum elle a dit d'accord banco
compris musulmans qui ne pensent pas
emmanuel macron lui aussi un il était
anti finance le le le monde de l'élite
comme eux avec nous
aujourd'hui à saint denis voilà date
d'abstention mais sans doute une
symbolique aujourd'hui on l'a dit le 21
abstention un petit peu plus élevé
qu'aux qu'au premier tour à qui est-ce
que ça participe
on sait que l'électorat d'emmanuel
macron sociologiquement il est plus
civique d'accord t'es gorille csp +
cadres professions j'ai tapé dans la
politique plus diplômée motivée aussi
par respectives de deux la victoire
l'électorat de marine le pen et
participe pas aux élections d'une
manière générale mais ce motif peut-être
davantage pour cette candidate
voilà à priori ça devrait s'équilibrer
ça ne devrait ni pénaliser un camp ni
avantage bien donc on a vu que
finalement régionales l'abstention
n'avait pas servi marine le pen plutôt
le contraire mais là c'était une
abstention record tes deux tiers
d'abstention mais on est dans le temps
dans l'ain vers saint lazare 72% de
participation c'est vraiment l'élection
qui mobilise le plus les français ce qui
m'amène à vous poser la question des
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon au
premier tour on a assez peu vu marine le
pen finalement elle est allée les
chercher on imaginait ça on a vu
emmanuel macron ce week end à marseille
aller à marseille une ville où jean luc
mélenchon est arrivé en tête parler
d'écologie pendant presque une heure
marine le pen assez peu pendant le débat
hier soir pas vraiment d'allusions pour
qu'ils vont voter les électeurs de jean
luc mélenchon ce fameux trésor de guerre
le magot qui faute compris la récupérer
vous avez raison c'est 7 millions 700
mille voire et c'est vraiment avec
l'abstention c'est la clé du deuxième
tour alors quand on regarde les les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]